que le sénat a adopté le pass vaccinale
la nuit dernière il a été voté à
242 voix pour et 69 voix contre vous le
voyez les amendements par rapport à la
version originale adopté le 6 janvier
dernier à l'assemblée sont nombreux de
quoi alimenter bien sûr et les
discussions tout à l'heure entre les
députés et les sénateurs qui vont devoir
se mettre d'accord sur sur ces
amendements on va en parler justement
avec notre reporter david khalifa qui
est devant le sénat
[Musique]
bonjour david un texte qui a donc
largement été remanié par le sénat ce
qui n'est pas forcément du goût du
gouvernement
les discussions s'annoncent un petit peu
compliqué cet après midi en comics en
commission mixte paritaire
quelles sont ces changements qui vont
être débattues à l'assemblée la ville
est bien écouter à magali un principales
mesures qui contrarie fortement
l'exécutif c'est l'encadrement du pass
vaccinale il ne pourrait être imposé ou
maintenu que lorsque le nombre
d'hospitalisations a lieu commis 19
serait supérieure à dix mille patients
au niveau national son maintien
interviendrait que dans les départements
où au moins l'un de ces deux critères
suivants seraient remplies un taux de
vaccination inférieur à 80 % de la
population totale alors quand je dis
taux de vaccination c'est un schéma
complet de vaccination ou une
circulation active du virus philippe bas
le rapporteur a rappelé le caractère
fortement restrictif de liberté de ce
projet de loi autre point important le
pass vaccinale devrait seulement être
imposée aux personnes majeures les
mineurs de 12 à 17 ans resterait quant à
eux soumis à l'obligation de présenter
l'actuel passe sanitaire c'est à dire
qu'il pourrait participer aux activités
de loisirs en produisant le résultat
négatif d'un simple test de dépistage le
sénat a également voté en faveur d'une
autorisation parentale unique pour la
vaccination des 5 11 ans comme c'était
déjà le cas pour les 12 15 ans sur ce
point précis et bien les débats ont été
plutôt mouvementée écouter
l'autorité parentale elle est conjointe
et à force de faire des exceptions à
l'exercice de l'autorité conjointe des
parents ont fini par créer de grandes
difficultés parce que si on le fait pour
le vaccin qui n'est pas indispensable
pour les tout petits alors on dira qu'il
faut le faire pour beaucoup d'autres
choses essentielles il est important
situation de la famille en france que
nous puissions maintenir cette règle que
les décisions importantes pour l'enfant
mais on ne doit pas s'en désintéresser
quand on est l'un des deux parents il
faut les prendre ensemble et donc l'avis
est défavorable
et il faudra maintenant la vie d'un seul
parent pour la vaccination selon les
sénateurs autre mesure phare david les
patrons de bars et de restaurants n'ont
pas à vérifier l'identité de leurs
clients
oui le sénat a supprimé purement et
simplement cette possibilité ils
n'auront pas à procéder à des
vérifications d'identité pour s'assurer
de la concordance avec le pass vaccinale
dans le texte initial 1 votée par les
députés si les exploitants avaient un
doute sur l'authenticité de ce pass
vaccinale un présenter eh bien il
pourrait demander une justification
d'identité avec photographie mais ce
n'est pas leur rôle a estimé le sénat
concernant le télétravail là aussi les
sénateurs se sont montrés hostiles aux
propositions du gouvernement ils ont
supprimé les dispositions permettant de
sanctionner d'une amende administrative
allant jusqu'à 1000 euros par salarié
dans la limite de 50 mille euros les
entreprises ne jouant pas le jeu du coc
vide ne vont pas le jeu du télétravail 1
pour lutter contre l'épidémie ducobu 19
merci beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions on va suivre évidemment
l'évolution de de ce texte en commission
tout à leur merci